wenn wir jetzt mal beispielsweise auf
owl klicken sie mir wie ich als rennen
aussehen oh mein gott
hallo mein name ist herzlich willkommen
wir heute zu einem neuen video ihr seht
es bereits im titel eingeblendet diese
app verändert dein gesicht es ist
nämlich eine app ihn ist das halt in den
app store charts enorm weit oben
die youtuber haben wir schon gemacht und
war sap hey da bin ja ich bei der fei
sap geht es darum dass ich mich hier
schon sehen und ihr seht schon ab und zu
wenn ich jetzt beispielsweise hier
hingehen wird hier so ein komischer
kreis angezeigt sondern gesichtsform und
wenn ich auf mein gesicht gehe dann wird
mein gesicht hat erkannt was wollen wir
dieser app jetzt quasi machen kann ist
nicht kann jetzt beispielsweise ein foto
hier vorne machen das machen wir jetzt
beispielsweise einfach mal beim
o
ach ich bin offline mensch sagen wir das
doch daran erkennt man wieder meine
damen und herren dass diese komplette
app direkt alle bilder von euch
wahrscheinlich dann irgendein
unternehmen verkauft ich dachte ich das
ganz ohne internet funktioniert aber
auch kritik jetzt einfach mal hier drauf
jetzt hat er mein gesicht das ist jetzt
natürlich blöd gewesen dass ich
währenddessen gerade geredet habe auf
jeden fall hat er jetzt jemand normales
gesicht frau ist ja nicht wundervolles
foto von mir geworden und jetzt mal das
video hier so ein bisschen zu
strukturieren
ich werde jetzt einfach bilder von mir
machen ein paar verschiedene oder alte
bilder von mir nehmen die in dieser app
hochladen und einfach schauen die mich
diese app dann beispielsweise als
rentner darstellt oder als frau oder als
kind oder als baby oder keine ahnung war
es zudem habe ich euch auch auf twitter
gesagt dass ihr mir selbst von euch zu
senden sollte das heißt am ende werde
ich dann auch noch bilder die ihr von
euch gemacht habt in dieser app
reinpacken
ich freu mich bist original bild sieht
also so aus das heißt wir kriegen jetzt
einfach mal auf smile und da sie mir
schon die app verarbeitet das ganze
wir können jetzt auch noch mal auf
normales mal klicken also nicht aufs mal
zwei da bin ich jetzt auch gesehen was
sophie perez dass der dga wir können
jetzt unter anderen auch mal aufs board
klicken ich weiß nicht was da erhöhen
was ist der unterschied zwischen spark
und original das ist einfach so ein
bisschen heller oder so in der tat wenn
wir jetzt mal beispielsweise auf out
klicken sehen wir wie ich als rennen
ausgehen dass hier bin ich als rentner
alter meine damen und herren man sieht
auf jeden fall dass die app mega gut
funktioniert also ich finde das ist mit
die beste app die dein gesicht verändern
kann da seht ihr hier ist bei jamie
sponsored von face app oder so also ich
mache das nur weil ich die app cool
findet also so sehe ich normal aus und
wenn ich dann als rentner vorher gehe
beziehungsweise mich die app einfach mal
als senior da stellt sich so aus
das können schon hinkommen eigentlich
wir gehen jetzt einfach mal auf young dh
das wahrscheinlich meine haut so ein
bisschen gestraffte okay
sieht eigentlich nicht wirklich anders
als vorher als frau würde ich
tatsächlich oder steht irgendwie war
der weg des filters currently available
ende collage not only das heißt wir
können jetzt anscheinend darauf collage
gehen und jetzt hier beispielsweise
female reinpacken packen wir hier rennen
rein und hier am ende vielleicht nochmal
smile das heißt dann haben wir jetzt
quasi eine collage erstellt mit mir als
in verschiedenen
position deutlich teil das ganze jetzt
einfach mal auf twitter und zwar wie die
wir super lustig
aha
und posten
nein ich will das nicht bewerten ich
werde jetzt als nächstes mal ein bild
nehmen was sich irgendwie vor drei
wochen oder so auf meinem handy
wiedergefunden habe ein paar sekunden
später hier habe ich gerade genießt
ja klickt man einfach auf smile und
schauen wie's funktioniert das so gut
ich meine leute achtet mal hier auf
meine oberlippe also da sieht man
wirklich keine zähne und dann aufs maul
es sieht aus als hätte ich wirklich so
geguckt okay wie komme ich jetzt einfach
mal aufs maul 1 und dann haben wir das
ist tatsächlich nicht so gut geworden
aber er dieser unterschied das ist
einfach voll krank leute das geht doch
gar nicht mehr klar wie krank ist denn
diese apps park wird wahrscheinlich
wieder alles ein bisschen glatter sein
genau da bin ich ein bisschen blasser
jetzt auf ok wie sehe ich als trainer
okay
diese app ist einfach mega gut wenn ich
jung wäre würde das ganze so aussehen da
sehe ich wenig tatsächlich aus wie ein
baby wenn ich auf email drücken würde
würde ich so aussehen dass sie das
überhaupt nicht aussehen female bevor
ich beim friseur war letztens habe ich
das foto hier auf instagram hochgeladen
deswegen schauen wir mal wie es aussehen
würde wenn ich auf diesem bild lachen oh
mein gott
so richtig so lange beide lachen 1 würde
so aussehen ein bisschen anders bark ist
wahrscheinlich wieder die haut einfach
so ein bisschen geglättet genau wenn wir
auf holz klicken sich wow
dem bauern jetzt rentner so aus würde
wäre mir da schon ganz lieb als nächstes
bild nehme ich jetzt einfach mal ein
kumpel von mir ich weiß ich aber damit
einverstanden ist aber ich glaube schon
so sieht das foto normal aus und packt
jetzt einfach mal ins mein gott walther
ja
es sieht genauso aus wie
eine echte lacher aber ich würde sagen
ich nehme jetzt mal ein paar von euren
bildern die e mail zugeschickt habt hier
haben wir jemanden der murger aus meinem
shop hat und zwar den pizza wo die das
heißt dass jetzt das originalfoto wir
klicken einfach mal aufs maul sie ist
zwar eigentlich schon am lächeln aber
okay das heißt da sieht man jetzt
eigentlich keinen großen unterschied
beim lachen beim lachen 1 wenn wir das
darauf an wänden sehen wir dass sie mir
213 hat
und irgendwie sind ihre augen aus ein
bisschen hochgezogen worden also was ich
denke ich nicht sehr viel verändern da
die haut de schon relativ rein ist wir
nehmen jetzt mal holt und sehen wo
es sieht tatsächlich aus als wäre sie
jetzt irgendwie 50 60 oder so alt hat
schwede dass man wirklich erkennt dass
sie hier junge ist und hier noch so ein
bisschen älter mdm das ist ja voll krank
ich bin gespannt wie sie als mail
aussehen würde also als junge okay da
sieht man dass kein großer unterschied
als mädchen auch eigentlich nicht also
man erkennt auf jeden fall dass ein
mädchen ist das hier ist das nächste
wort und mit dem bearbeiten werden mit
klicken einfach mal noch 212 eigentlich
auch schon am lächeln aber gut seine
lippe wird ein bisschen hochgezogen das
wäre cool wenn man als
auswahlmöglichkeit anstatt zwei auch
sowas so unnormal nehmen könnte also das
heißt wenn jemand ein lachendes foto von
sich macht dass man denen auch bei sie
nicht lachen klatschen könnte so sieht
ja als älterer herr aus also ich finde
das kann man wirklich auch noch mehr
oder weniger durchgehen lassen wenn er
jung wäre wird er tatsächlich so
aussehen okay
ist ein schock
als nächste person haben wir sie hier am
start das heißt wir lassen sie einfach
mal lächeln altherr schweder der ablauf
ist immer gleich ich nehme ein foto
packe es dort rein und wundere mich mega
darüber wie krank das funktioniert das
ist original und das ist lächelnd es
könnte halt wirklich ihre natur eigene
lache sein als ältere dame würde sie so
aussehen und als jüngeres mädchen würde
wie so aussehen dass das hier ist
wirklich bisher somit das krasseste was
du bisher gemacht haben also ich meine
man sich ja wirklich das mal und so das
könnte wirklich wirklich von ihr sein
hier haben wir jetzt mehrere faces auf
dem foto das heißt wir wählen
beispielsweise malin hier vorne links
aus und haben jetzt quasi sein gesicht
was jetzt generiert wird das heißt
liegen mit als erstes auf smile und seen
alter schwede
ich weiß sorry leute ist es immer die
gleiche reaktion aber guckt euch an wie
krank das einfach ist es könnte wirklich
seine lache sein wenn wir jetzt auf jan
klicken sehr wahrscheinlich keinen
großen unterschied genau wie quasi
genauso wie vorher aber sind klicken sie
mir schon der embryo wir nehmen als
nächstes einfach mal ein foto von meinem
manager ilja das heißt das foto wird
geladen und wir sehen schon in ja mit
einem lachen auf diesem foto würde er
sieht aus wie vor ging es da hey leute
das ist einfach so krank die welt
das ist ja alles okay wie krieg mal aufs
bald da sind seine wangen einfach so ein
bisschen gepudert so sieht's aus
[Musik]
sogar sein bart ist grau geworden aber
das war es diese evolution von dem
lachen und dann wieder hier das sogar
die mundwinkel hier einfach hochgezogen
werden der bart angepasst wird wie krank
ist der algorithmus von dieser app bitte
wir haben wir marcel scorpion meine
damen und herren das heißt er lacht ja
eh nicht so häufig das ziel setzt ihn
einfach mal ein lachen auf meine leute
ich hätte angst vor dieser person in der
dunkelheit auch hier klickt man einfach
auf bolt bei marcel scorpion okay da
sehen wir erst relativ alt geworden bei
young ist relativ
man sollte mir definitiv diese app
wegnehmen wenn ihr blog habt das nicht
das noch mal machen mit mehr bildern von
euch mit vielleicht bildern von anderen
youtube und die dann älter mache oder
als frau darstelle oder sogar lasten
leute schaffen wir 50.000 leute seid
alles tot wenn ihr mehr davon sehen
wollen als nächstes haben wir hier ein
foto von john key ich habe das foto
nicht gemacht hatte irgendjemand mein
handy so sieht ja original aus und wir
packen jetzt einfach mal 1 mal drauf
leute ich bin ultra geschmacklos
baby wird er so aussehen
der bruder von massen scorpion sein
nehmen wir als nächstes wieder ein foto
was ihr mir auf twitter eingesendet habt
also dass das originale wir kriegen
einfach mal aufs maul und wo gott
die mundwinkel werden immer viel zu
übertrieben nach außen gezogen finde ich
also der smiley also wenn die lachen
würde ich glaube sie hätte nicht so
einen großen mund als ältere personen
würde die nette dame so aussehen als
jüngeres mädchen würde die so okay das
ist kein unterschied eigentlich hier
haben wir wieder ein foto was mütter 1
gesendet wurde sie lacht zwar eigentlich
schon aber wir kriegen einfach mal
trotzdem wieder auf das lachen sehen des
40 jahren nichts
erinnert sich wirklich nichts und jetzt
wäre es halt cool wenn man
beispielsweise sowas sagen könnte wie
facebook macht auch vielleicht das
lachen weckt aber das wird ja vielleicht
an demnächst noch im zugefügt oder so
weil ich meinen die app ist es sehr sehr
kurzer zeit draußen und sie schon mega
im heim als ältere person würde diese
person von twitter so aussehen da sieht
man auch keine mega großen unterschied
und als jüngere person würde sie so
aussehen also ich glaube das liegt
einfach daran dass das gesicht
verhältnismäßig relativ klein ist leute
jetzt als abschluss werde ich noch mal
ein foto von mir machen und zwar gucke
ich jetzt einfach mal ganz normal 2000
jahre später mein foto wird bearbeitet
meine damen und herren und dann schauen
wir uns sofort nochmal an genau das hier
ist das originale und ich gucke wir
einfach mal wien smile aussehen würde
bei meinem
an der stelle würde ich jetzt aber auch
das video beenden wenn der damen und
herren ich hoffe es hat euch gefallen
wenn etwas getan hat wie gesagt lasst
leichter wenn ihr das ganze nochmal
sehen wollt ihr findet jetzt hier ein
smiley eingeblendet wenn ihr darauf
gelegt könnte meinen kanal kostenlos
abonnieren verpasst dadurch keine videos
mehr das ist mega cool dass ich wollte
das so als wäre es mein eigenes produkt
mich zu abonnieren
darum findet ihr auf meinen shop
eingeblendet und hier unten ist ein
anderes video verlinkt so getraut